classy joint class a giant I like it I
like it you there we need to have a
conversation oh okay um you've got my
attention I'm always looking for people
who know how to handle themselves in
dangerous situations let's do that one I
hear you bill hey I don't mind danger so
long as I get paid well you'll get paid
the starting rate like everybody else
[ __ ] ass off you turned out to be as
useful as you claim then we can talk
about a race by the way I'm Edward
Deegan you'll mostly be working for me
he'll need to talk to my boss first his
name is Jack cabin he likes dick
personal asst yeah they have a shitty
armor okay he's careful like that come
down to cabin house in beacon hill and
asked to talk to Jack I'll let him know
you're coming thanks brah thanks brah
all right we're starting a quest that I
called special delivery and it's your
boy psychobabble with Donald Trump right
here so let's do this but just let's do
this okay y'all [ __ ] just love
this [ __ ] y'all Ian add my porridge like
it's sitting in on a mother [ __ ] pics
a sec you know what I'm saying promise
you know what I'm saying sisters o Lord
Almighty [ __ ] loading screens what
the [ __ ] is a [ __ ] okay okay at where is
the Cabot house [ __ ] okay okay
right shout on map all right what's the
closest thing here haymarket mall let's
do that let's do this mm-hmm quantum
color look at that thing I like I like
drinking things that glow like glow
sticks mm-hmm
and I like yeah right a bunch of [ __ ]
haters oh [ __ ] get a little injured here
okay okay hmm the [ __ ] silver
Shadwell mu'fucka there's that up there
oh I like that okay I can't take this
I'll take this [ __ ] ain't a quick want
my [ __ ] sorry guys I know this is very
unprofessional and I but a baby's gotta
do what a baby's gonna tear [ __ ] okay
okay all right Cabot house Cabot house I
think that's it right north northwest a
little bit this guy yeah I want to get
on the wrong way that would [ __ ]
embarrassing
mmm private property no trespassing okay
how much is this the [ __ ] up why is this
not working go away and I don't you I'm
here to talk to Jack Cabot oh it's you
good come on in [ __ ] [ __ ]
let's go meet the boss
lead on [ __ ] [ __ ] its water so
close there [ __ ] I don't cuz I don't
like the particles getting in Jack the
new guy is here places this place is
very nice what's go check nice loose
picture you got there yeah pleased to
meet you jack and I am very pleased to
meet you Edward finds it tiresome but I
always like to know personally everyone
who works for sure have a seat how about
a drink Edward the good bourbon aid I
don't turn but ok sure now before we get
down to business I have a question I
like to ask all my new employees have X
really determining to rock network the
question is this do you believe there is
other intelligent life in the universe
and yes the universe is a big place
anything could be out there oh well just
like Trump to not give a straight answer
but i'm not talking about flying saucers
and little green men i'm talking about
the hidden history of our planet the
very origins of human civilization
ancient powers that modern science even
at its pinnacle could barely begin to
comprehend hmm that's really interesting
it's more human too much talking yes
tell you say that it's become my life's
work my approach is to combine a
rigorous scientific method while keeping
an absolutely open mind okay oh my idea
of science is putting a battery and a
flashlight okay my father excavated a
city in aruba Holly in Arabia which he
dated
two more than 4,000 years before the
rise of any known human civilization the
structures and artifacts were or by
means I've spent my life trying to
decipher what you Jax can I started I
just get carried away sometimes you're
sending him to look for the missing show
yeah well then I better leave you to it
we'll talk more about this some other
time when things are less rough it isn't
important welcome to the family okay
thank you officially hired great I'm
ready to get to work good that's part of
the job by the way it's best to keep an
open mind Jack maybe yeah nice trick a
guy but he's definitely not crazy the
job I got for you is simple jack o is a
facility north of the city there's an
important package than when missing me
come down here I need you to track it
down and bring you back to any questions
no no
for starters what's this package of new
people it's a metal case hogan vials of
serum you don't need to worry about what
it is Jack needs it for his research
that's all you need to know you should
carry the Carson State insane asylum
don't let the name procreates just a
secure building that were using we think
the courier got ambushed as he was
leaving the place the guards heard
gunfire in the distance but we don't
know attacker would happen check in with
Maria at Parsons she's in charge of the
security force there she can point you
in the right direction you all set then
I'll set yep see you soon with the
package good luck don't get killed in my
first job ok thank you thank you ok ok
let's let's see where the [ __ ] we gotta
go yeah hmm
hmm [ __ ] load skids and if I can
calendar way oh wow the [ __ ] I put
pasta in front of my face and putting
leg down my today's you know when I was
saying on MLK today's Jesus like [ __ ]
10 years a lot of this [ __ ] [ __ ] DMV
like it oh we're ready to go okay talk
to the guard captain all the way fog in
that great great great great great great
great great
that's badass suit on their way I'm
gonna throw some this miscellaneous [ __ ]
get get look at my [ __ ] Barbara did
the [ __ ] stupid as [ __ ] there you go
that I comes [ __ ] slow too buddy and
I feel like you know if not everyone was
made equal
ok ok I can I guess I guess sorry just
like faded out there for a second hey
Alex and I was Jack's now to Jack's guys
uh what is that [ __ ] cars dog hey
check out this [ __ ] i use that
oh this straight you know i just put up
h baskets and just walk around my
basketball waiting for someone you know
and some sam dog its own sayin little
8-bit mixtape Ian out mmhmm yeah [ __ ]
assess this Sylum who is that nutjob
that mercenary is about to get [ __ ] up
that's all I gotta say just don't bring
any trouble down on us okay I was about
to kill all them hello ma'am limits best
move along shut the [ __ ] out [ __ ]
edwardian sent me I'm looking for a
missing time Trump's next disgusting
package pretty sure we know where it is
the guys that shot been are holed up in
the Parsons creamery just north of here
that's all I needed to know well then I
guess we're done yeah yeah careful it's
weird that they're still hanging around
so cool it's like they're scouting the
placer good good good I agree is weird
but [ __ ] yeah matches ok ok ok let's
gotta kill these camry [ __ ] Raiders
are so easy you just throw one shots
yeah I'm about to [ __ ] these [ __ ] up
me and mean Kronk over here uh yeah dude
they're so [ __ ] close why are you
like how can they sleep at night they
say they're holed up in the scream is
that a [ __ ] boat up there okay whoo
boom Shakalaka baby boom shakalaka can't
say cuz you got a [ __ ] bullet and a
head [ __ ] uh [ __ ] there goes
crowd we don't do that right here oh
good gut gut nice shiny look at [ __ ]
Trump with a rifle he looks [ __ ] good
oh wait a [ __ ] face chase s
let me get some help like I'd lie to him
up like [ __ ] a toothpaste mm-hmm we got
trampled a [ __ ] badass Oh Jackie
gonna take that bad boy sees any more
good stuff here it's gotta be right as a
Raider down no nope just quick quick
search not that nap advanced advanced
advanced let me just take a gander up
here what the heck okay let's do this
let's do this okay
I'm here not acceptable Emma Jean is
missing and I walked by cloud she's not
missing mother you know did you find out
what happened to the career yeah some
raiders set up camp near Parsons in it
tequila I don't like Raiders operating
so close what about the serum he was
here there was only this one file XOX